MORE THAN STORIES SHE'S COVERED
AS A JOURNALIST.
IT HAS DIVIDED HER FAMILY.
BRITTANY MEJIA JUST WROTE A
PIECE ABOUT THE DEATH OF HER
UNVACCINATED GRANDMOTHER FROM
COVID AND HOW OPINIONS OVER THE
VACCINES HAVE CAUSED SUCH A
DIVIDE.
HERE IS PART OF HER REMARKABLE
PIECE.
QUOTE, FOR MANY, COVID-19 IS
WHAT FORCED THEM TO STAY HOME
AND WEAR MASKS TO KEEP OTHERS
SAFE.
THE VIRUS EXISTED LARGELY IN THE
ABSTRACT.
FOR ME, IT'S WHAT CAME TO DEFINE
THESE LAST TWO YEARS, PERSONALLY
AND PROFESSIONALLY.
IT'S WHAT TORE THROUGH MY
FAMILY, INFECTING NEARLY 30
RELATIVES HERE AND IN MEXICO
JUST ON MY MOM'S SIDE.
IT'S WHAT LED ME TO DRIVE MY
COUSINS TO SAY GOODBYE TO THEIR
FATHER WHO WAS ON A VENTILATOR.
IT'S WHAT WAS NOW STEALING THE
HEART OF OUR FAMILY.
BRITTNY JOINS ME.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THIS
EXPERIENCE.
IT MUST HAVE BEEN VERY HARD TO
WRITE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME ON.
IT REALLY WAS.
I THINK THIS IS THE MOST
PERSONAL ARTICLE I'VE EVER
WRITTEN, AND IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT, BUT ALMOST CATHARTIC,
I THINK, TO BE ABLE TO WRITE HER
STORY.
>> YOU DESCRIBE YOUR
GRANDMOTHER, AND FORGIVE ME
PRONUNCIATION AS A CHIGONA, AND
FORGIVE MY PRONUNCIATION, A BAD
ASS.
>> YES.
SHE WAS DEFINITELY A CHIGONA.
SHE WAS THE EXAMPLE FOR ALL OF
US, ESPECIALLY THE WOMEN IN OUR
FAMILY.
SHE EMIGRATED HERE WITH HER
CHILDREN, FIVE OF HER CHILDREN
TO START OVER FROM MEXICO AND
WAS A NURSE IN MEXICO, BUT HAD
TO START OVER AGAIN HERE AND
STARTED WORKING IN A FACTORY
SEWING BURLAP SACKS.
SAVED ENOUGH MONEY, BOUGHT A
HOUSE IN HIGHLAND PARK, REALLY
REACHED THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I THINK FOR ALL OF US, IT WAS
JUST SUCH AN EXAMPLE FOR HOW WE
WANTED TO LIVE AND HOW WE WANTED
TO KIND OF PASS THAT DOWN
THROUGH THE GENERATIONS.
>> YOU TWEETED THAT EVEN THE
RESPONSES, BRITTYY YOU'VE GOTTEN
TO THIS ARTICLE ILLUSTRATE THE
DIVISION THAT TORE APART YOUR
OWN FAMILY.
I WONDER IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
THAT EXPERIENCE, ANY ADVICE OR
LESSONS FOR OTHERS WATCHING WHO
ARE ALSO DEALING WITH DIVIDES IN
THEIR FAMILY OVER THIS.
>> IT'S BEEN REALLY CHALLENGING.
EVEN THE FUNERAL WAS THIS WEEK,
THE SERVICE, THE WAKE,
EVERYTHING WAS THIS WEEK.
EVEN THEN, IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
SEE FAMILY MEMBERS UNMASKED IN
THE CHURCH, UNVACCINATED FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO WERE UNMASKED.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE, AND I THINK THERE IS THIS
DIVISION THAT EXISTS.
IT'S THE TRUTH FOR A LOT OF
FAMILIES.
I GOT SO MANY EMAILS SAYING
THEIR WERE DEALING WITH THE SAME
TYPE OF SITUATION.
I THINK FOR ME, A HUGE THING --
MY SISTERS AND I WENT TO THE
CEMETERY TOGETHER.
I WENT WITH TWO OF THEM.
ON THE WAY THERE, ONE OF MY
SISTERS AND I KEPT TALKING TO
THE OTHER AND TRYING TO WEAR HER
DOWN A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE SHE
DIDN'T WANT TO GET VACCINATED.
WHEN SHE TOLD ME TO MAKE THE
APPOINTMENT ON THE DRIVE TO THE
CEMETERY, WHICH WE DID FOR THIS
FRIDAY, I JUST FELT RELIEVED.
I THINK THERE WERE TENSE MOMENTS
BETWEEN US, AND WE DON'T SEE EYE
TO EYE ON SOME THINGS.
BUT FOR ME IT WAS WORTH IT TO
KEEP HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND TO PUSH THROUGH THAT.
I THINK THAT'S THE BEST ADVICE I
COULD GIVE, IS THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND TO MAKE
THOSE APPOINTMENTS.
IT MAKES IT KIND OF EASIER AND
TAKES AWAY THE EXTRA STEP FROM
SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
YOU EVEN HAD TO BRING MASKS TO
THE FUNERAL, N95 MASKS BEGGING
PEOPLE TO WEAR THEM.
YOU WRITE IN THE PIECE "I AM SO
TIRED."
WHAT HAS BEEN MOST EXHAUSTING
FOR YOU, BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
COVERING IT DAY IN AND OUT AS A
JOURNALIST AND THEN FIGHTING
THIS FIGHT PERSONALLY.
>> IT'S BEEN REALLY HARD FOR ME.
I THINK EVEN THIS PAST WEEK I
WAS IN AN ICU, AND EVERYONE IN
THE ICU WAS UNVACCINATED, A LOT
OF THEM ON VENTILATORS.
I THINK IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR ME
BECAUSE SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE
I'M JUST PAINTED AS THE
UNREASONABLE ONE IN MY FAMILY BY
SOME FAMILY MEMBERS, EVEN THOUGH
REALLY WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS
MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS PROTECTED
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT US TO LOSE
ANYBODY ELSE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN
ESPECIALLY CHALLENGING, IS BEING
ABLE TO